Село Коритне, що за 60 кілометрів від Чернівців, оживає щосереди,
коли торговці з довколишніх міст привозять на продаж різний крам.
У селі, де народився митрополит Онуфрій -
предстоятель Української православної церкви Московського патріархату,
варто було лиш зачепити тему Томосу, як одразу схвальні відгуки лунають у торговельних рядах.
Коби Бог дав! То ми ж українці, коби Бог дав! Получили   Томос!
Ми за!
Те, що відомий земляк - ярий противник автокефалії, тут пояснюють просто.
В нього був батюшка тато і вони з роками звикли до старого устрою.
В Росії вчився він, у Москві, тай вони вже такі віддані Росії.
У цій хатіна околиці села 74 роки тому народився митрополит Онуфрій.
Подвір’я знаходиться на горі й звідси добре видно бані старого Свято-Миколаївського храму.
Суди, ймовірно, дитиною, Онуфрій ходив на недільну службу.
Саме на території цього храму знаходимо тих, кому Томос не потрібен
і хто, наслідуючи слова Митрополита Онуфрія,
майбутнє об’єднання православної церкви вважає незаконним,
а прибічників Київського Патріархату називає ”розкольниками”.
Є у вас в родині ті, хто ходять в церкву КП?
Є - Є - Є. І що ви думаєте, і що? І біда. І плач душу вириває.
І в душі може вони жаліють, що так поступили, що розкол.
Але через свою гордість, не знають,як повернуться, не можуть уже переступити назад.
Назад уже вороття нема.
Об’єднану церкву та нового її очільника тут не визнаватимуть.
"Неканонічними"називають і останні рішення Константинопольської церкви щодо України.
Ми бачимо, що без всякого діалогу Константинопольська Православна Церква,
яка визнавала нашу церкву законною… сам Вселенський патріарх заявляв,
що він в Україні бачить лише одну канонічну церкву на чолі з Блаженнішим митрополитом Онуфрієм.
Ми бачимо, що тут вже позиція помінялась, що дуже дивно для глави церкви.
Протоієрей Василь довго пояснює офіційну позицію церкви.
Та те, як молиться за ту частину прихожан, які відійшли від неї.
Збереження і примноження громади - особиста відповідальність перед митрополитом Онуфрієм.
Бо саме він колись і просив отця Василя стати настоятелем цього сторічного храму.
Утім тут, у Коритному, здається, кожен мешканець має свої власні спогади з очільником УПЦ.
Пам’ятаю, як на стадіоні у футбол з ним грали.
Хороша людина він,
але чого він…
не можу сказати..
Дід Іван якраз з тієї частини громади села,
яка захотіла вийти з-під юрисдикції УПЦ Московського патріархату.
Зі своєї невеликої пенсії він відкладає гроші для побудови нової церкви.
Її за кошти громади почали зводити ще у 2015 році, після початку подій на Сході України.
А вже за два роки освятили бані.
І поки верхній храм Церкви святого рівноапостольного князяВолодимира добудовують,
у нижньому вже проводять службу.
Отець Петро не без хвилювання каже: 15 грудня вона може бути особливою.
Всі священики чекають на настанови від владики, від своїх архієреїв.
Якщо їм прийде інформація з Києва, щоб згадувати нового,
тоді вони дають нам через благочинних, що  ось міняється, нового згадуємо.
Населення у Коритному чимале - майже дві з половиною тисячі людей.
Утім воно чітко ділиться за релігійним і політичними поглядами:
ті, хто очікують на Томос, звинувачують у війні на сході України - Росію.
Інші кажуть, що вже мають єдину Українську православну церкву.
Томос фактично вже наданий Україні, наша церква вже канонічна, православна,
і патріарх Олексій надав томос, і наша церква автономна, незалежна,
і я вважаю, що це трохи політичне питання.
Дуже хочемо, щоб була українська церква, переживаємо, щоб не було ніякого..
щоб було все добре між нами, щоб ми були дружні, щоб наше село не ділилось,
щоб ми всі разом, бо Бог один на небі, і тому, добре було б, аби все було… аби ми всі разом.
Ніколи не ділились.
А ми таку думку маємо, а вони іншу.
За це не треба ні бити, ні вбивати, це в усьому світі так є, що різні думки.
Попри релігійні та політичні розбіжності громадам різних патріархатів
досі вдається мирно співіснувати.
Схоже, що дотриматись основної християнської заповіді - "возлюби ближнього свого" -
на батьківщині митрополита Онуфрія вдалося.
Вірянисподіваються, що так буде і після об’єднавчого собору.